we're going to take a look at some
photos that are in the news today photo
number three just outside of Newport
legs seven the volvo ocean race began
thank you photo editor era court for
giving me this photo to talk about of
course now we're going to do race
analysis Tom likes called a hockey game
let me show you what's going on right
now they have just rounded the buoy
started the there they're on their way
out to the ocean of course the what is
loading is not quite yet there is a map
of where the boats actually are but um
there is economics in this which is the
two boats in the lead right now Abu
Dhabi ocean racing dongfeng races
different from the America's Cup why is
different for the Americans kept well
it's more so the America's Cup is
nations competing against each other of
course in all cases you basically it's
basically our Kiwis against your Kiwis
it's the New Zealanders and the
Frenchman that are really really good at
sailboat racing but this is if you look
at the organizations that are paying for
this Abu Dhabi ocean racing dongfeng
which is a Chinese team we're learning a
lot about the market for luxury goods
yes of course but the rich guys have
changed Tom that is what's different
alright ah we got to talk about sailboat
racing thank you number two in France
Annie Jones the u.s. takes part in the
red bull cliff diving World Series
divers leap off a 90-foot high platform
on top of the 14th century Saint
Nicholas towers 13 divers competed
75,000 fans watch from the streets
that's amazing I think what Red Bull has
done with marketing did is in juice
what's their extraordinary yeah they've
got it done it's 90 feet that's like
nine stories eight stories high that's I
that's I mean to you alright ok here's a
lie that is that Tom that's definitely
not a bad it's not a dude but alright
number one Tom I'm gonna let you call
this in Sochi Vladimir Putin here
playing hockey scored eight goals I
think yeah I'm sure he did had an
amazing day he's waiting on some real
players or Pavel Bure and a few others
that are giants in hockey but yeah it's
it's a no what's the difference in
presidential golf he's doing
he's doing hockey it's just that Super
Bowl deal of mulligans in presidential
golfing here's you get a hockey
Mulligan's job oh yeah yeah so I mean
that's what I mean three goals is a
hat-trick what's eight there he is he's
moving he's a skates are two big guys at
any bro in the history of the NHL scored
eight goals and again no I don't believe
that is occurred it certainly nuts this
year but there is a the first hockey
player of Russia out doing it and he
needs some power skinny oh look you want
a cup he was so good they gave him a
good time